let's say that we have the equation 6
plus 3w
is equal to
the square root of 2w plus 12
plus
2w see if you can pause the video and
solve for w and it might have more than
one solution so keep that in mind
all right now let's work through this
together so the first thing i'd like to
do whenever i see one of these radical
equations is just isolate the radical on
one side of the equation so let's
subtract 2w from both sides
i want to get rid of that 2w from the
right-hand side i just want the radical
sign and if i subtract 2w from both
sides what am i left with well on the
left-hand side i am left with
plus 3w minus 2w well 3 of something
take away 2 of them you're going to be
left with w 6 plus w is equal to
these cancel out we're left with the
square root of 2w
plus 12. now to get rid of the radical
we're going to square both sides
and we've seen before that this process
right over here it's a little bit tricky
because when you're squaring a radical
in a radical equation like this and then
you solve you might be involving you
might find an extraneous solution what
do i mean by that well we're going to
get the same result whether we square
this or whether we square that because
when you square a negative it becomes a
positive but those are fundamentally two
different equations we only want the
solutions that satisfy the one that
doesn't have the negative there so
that's why we're going to test our
solutions to make sure that they're
valid for our original equation
so if we square both sides on
the left hand side we're going to have
well it's going to be w squared
plus 2 times their
2 times their product so 2 times 6 times
w so that's 12 w
plus 6 squared 36
is equal to
now if you take the square root if you
and square it you're going to be left
with 2w plus 12. now we can subtract 2w
and 12 from both sides so let's do that
so then we can get into kind of a
standard quadratic form so let's
subtract 2w from both sides
and let's subtract 12 from both sides
so subtract 12 from the right subtract
12 here and once again i just want to
get rid of this on the right hand side
and i am going to be left with
i am going to be left with
on the left hand side it's going to be w
squared see 12w minus 2w is plus 10w
and then 36 minus 12 is plus 24 is equal
to
0.
and let's see to solve this let's see is
this factorable are there two numbers
that add up to 10 and whose product is
24. well what jumps out at me is 6 and
4. so we can rewrite this as w plus 4
times w plus 6 is equal to zero
and so if i have the product of two
things equaling zero well to solve this
either one or both of them could be
equal to zero zero times anything is
going to be zero so w plus four is equal
to zero
or
w plus six is equal to zero and over
here if you subtract four from both
sides you get w is equal to negative
four
or subtract six from both sides here w
is equal to negative six
now let's let's verify that these
actually are solutions to our original
equation remember our original equation
was 6
i'll rewrite it here our original
equation was 6 plus 3w is equal to the
square root of 2w plus 12
plus 2w so let's see if w is equal to
negative 4
if w is equal to negative 4 right over
let me do this indifferent is equal to
negative 4 so that's going to be 6 plus
3 times negative 4 is equal to the
square root of
2 times negative 4
plus 12 plus 2 times negative 4.
so this would be this is negative 12
here
this is negative 8 here this is negative
8 here so you have 6 plus negative 12
which is negative 6 is equal to
the square root of negative 8 plus 12 is
plus negative 8
so that would be negative 6 is equal to
2 plus negative 8 which is absolutely
true so this is definitely a solution
and let's try w is equal to negative 6.
so w
is equal to negative 6
so we're going to get
if we look up here we're going to have 6
plus 3 times negative 6 is equal to the
square root of 2 times negative 6
plus 12 plus
2 w
so this is going to be negative 18. this
is going to be negative 12. if this is
negative 12 negative 12 plus 12 is 0
square root of 0 this is all this 0
and then 2 times and actually let me
i should have written a w there i should
have written it 2 times negative 6. so
back to what i was doing
this right over here is negative 18.
this
is 2 times negative 6 plus 12 this is
all
0. square root of 0 0 and then this is
negative 12.
so you get 6 plus negative 18 which is
negative 12 is equal to 0 plus negative
12 negative 12 which is absolutely
correct so these are actually both
solutions to our original radical
equation